Daniel Ellsberg leading activists in the
nuclear freeze movement author of the
Pentagon Papers during the Vietnam War
how do the goals of American liberals
today differ from those who fought to
end the conflict in Vietnam the title of
tonight's talk are you asking me that is
one of the questions and that we'll be
talking about tonight I think that what
people are learning today about contra
gate day by day as it leaks out
corresponds very much to what the
Pentagon Papers had to reveal 15 years
ago about our government policy making
in those days it took documents to
convince an American citizen that his
president might be lying to him that's
not true today it's because the Pentagon
Papers did come out and they saw an
awful lot of documents that were very
painful reading at the time that men we
voted for work for campaign for I'd
worked for several presidents had been
all carrying out a policy that was
entirely different from what they told
us different aims different different
expectations in some cases violating
laws violating our Constitution doing it
secretly a covert foreign policy that
was out of control of the public I think
that's what we're hearing about today
and that's why we're about to have
hearings on that subject I expect to
learn a lot from those hearings I just
got cable and c-span television for the
first time of my life in expectation of
those hearings I want to follow them I
hope you enjoy them would you explain
for our viewers who may have forgotten
or may be too young to remember your
role and the Pentagon Papers
well you described me as the author of
the Pentagon Papers that's not that's a
little misleading I did draft one of the
volumes of the Pentagon Papers there
were 43 main volumes plus some
negotiations of items all top secret
dealing with the history this was the
title history of US decision-making in
Vietnam from 1945 to 1968 the project
started in 1968 and like most Americans
the people doing the study in the
Pentagon of which I was one thought the
war was about to end
at that point President Johnson had just
said that he would not run again he was
asking for negotiations and people
thought that it was about over actually
it had seven years to go I was working
on a project then the Pentagon so-called
Pentagon Papers which was to learn
lessons from the Pentagon from the
Vietnam War and when that study was
completed by 69 I was at the RAND
Corporation on contract to the Defense
Department with I was the only
researcher in the country authorized to
have the entire study in my possession
to do a project on lessons from Vietnam
and as I read those volumes
I thought increasingly as I saw the war
going on that these were lessons that
shouldn't be just mine to learn and
shouldn't be just the Pentagon's to
learn that the American public needed to
know this information about how they'd
been lied to and how they'd been
manipulated into that war so in 1969 I
began copying those top-secret writings
that were in my safe I had authorized
possession to them and giving them what
I was not authorized to do giving them
to Senator Fulbright then chairman of
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
and he expected to hold hearings but
ultimately did not hold hearings on the
basis of those documents and eventually
two invasions later Laos and Cambodia
many American deaths many Vietnamese
deaths later I gave the documents to the
New York Times and when they were
enjoined for the first time in our
history from publishing I gave copies to
the Washington Post and a 17 newspapers
at all for which I was put on trial
facing 115 years in prison you of course
never went to trial perhaps you can I
went on a trial you when I was five and
a half months in in court but about the
time that we were due to go to summation
and go to the jury after five and a half
months in court
nearly after nearly two years in the
court proceedings a series of
revelations came out of the so-called
plumbers are revealing that the White
House had illegally done operations the
analogy to today is not coincidental
it's almost a replay that a set of
people in the White House had
and doing burglaries I had gone into my
former psychoanalysts office and trying
to get material to blackmail me into
silence I'd been there in an attempt to
incapacitate me or murder me and doing a
speech in Washington phones had been
tapped 17 News men had been tapped in
many including uh members of the NSC
staff I'd been overheard on those and
the records had been concealed so as to
keep them out of my trial and after ten
days of continuous revelations of the
CIA and so forth all charges were
dismissed against me by the judge on
grounds of gross governmental misconduct
I believe by the way that we are in for
revelations of a very similar nature in
the coming months what makes you believe
that it's very clear that the everything
we've heard everything that mr. Meese
has so far officially disclosed about
Colonel North's operations indicate
covert operations run in violation of
laws of Congress and in this case not it
would seem against an American citizen
but against the law and against the
citizens of another country u Nicaragua
it would there seems very clear as many
people have already concluded in the
Senate and the house which is why they
set up the committee the major laws have
been broken by the executive branch and
by the White House role the president is
not yet clear but the role of people
working directly for him is clear we
have a spectacle of an executive branch
out of democratic control an executive
branch that has not submitted to the
legislative authority of Congress in the
area where Congress has a constitutional
authority to control of the budget we
were talking with Daniel Ellsberg who
has just described his role in the
Pentagon Papers during the Vietnam War
he is currently an activist in the
nuclear freeze movement I'll give a
little of his lengthy background he was
a strategic analyst for the RAND
Corporation for a number of years
different periods in 1964 he joined the
Defense Department as the special
assistant to the assistant secretary for
international security affairs went to
Vietnam was a State Department official
in 1965 and 66 while at Grand the RAND
Corporation in 1961 developed the first
Ken
the administration guidelines for
general nuclear war plans he has been
active with the nuclear-free strategy
Task Force and the American piece test
which is demonstrated in Washington and
at the Nevada testing site since the
early seventies you've lectured in
taught college seminars you were in the
US Marine Corps from 1954 to 1957 I
believe do you find in the nuclear
freeze movement many of the same
liberals who've led the fight to end the
war in Vietnam
well many yes but the movements do
differ quite a bit the freeze movement
is not a campus-based movement
particularly and of course it doesn't
have the veteran phenomenon either when
it's a in terms of people who support
who want to see a bilateral that is a
mutual two-sided ending to the arms race
by the Soviet Union and by the US and
ending to testing deployment and
production of nuclear weapons that's 80%
of the public that's the public I mean
it's not the Vietnam War movement it's
not any movement that's the public to a
first approximation except for the
people in the White House in the
Pentagon and 20% minority in terms of
however the people have been quite
active and you get a much older
generation of doing both of all kinds of
activities in this movement and I think
you got in Vietnam which was much more
of a youthful of protest movement on the
whole it's much more broadly based all
groups in society I think are
represented in it it's about I'm here in
Washington this weekend to attend a
meeting of the same Board of Directors
that's committee for a same nuclear
policy and I was just elected the board
the that's a 30-year old organization
working it's been working against
nuclear testing all that time they voted
this weekend and while I was here
to merge with the freeze the National
freeze campaign which in terms of
actually activists 1,700 chapters is the
largest grassroots movement probably
this country has seen of any kind and
the two groups the freeze campaign and
and sane merged just now I think it'll
be a quite unprecedented
lobby citizens Lobby and grassroots
movement focusing right now on ending at
last after that 30 years campaign ending
the testing of nuclear weapons we want
to see the u.s. join the Soviet
moratorium on nuclear testing the
Soviets cessation of testing preferably
right now while before the Soviets test
again we will be going to the telephones
in just a minute or two please call us
if you have a question or a comment on
any of the subjects we have already
raised or any others that you're
interested in the numbers which you will
see at the base of your screen or if
you're calling from the eastern and
central time zones area two oh two six
two eight two five two five if you're
calling from the Pacific or mountain
time zones area 202 seven eight three
two seven two seven do you find in the
liberal opposition to aid to the Contras
or to getting involved in the war in
Nicaragua some of the leaders of the old
liberal movement in Vietnam well again
when you say leaders of that movement
they've moved on most of them to other
things hobby Hoffman has not I noticed
these just facing trial and has been to
Nicaragua a number of times I came into
that movement indeed after 68 and after
Chicago protests I came from the RAND
Corporation for the Defense Department
from a different background most of
people in that movement in a way my my
entry was like that of the veterans in
Vietnam who'd had that experience and
came into it but the point is I think
that the movement against our
intervention in Nicaragua represents
people young and old who did learn a
very different lesson from that war than
President Reagan learned they learned
that they don't want to reproduce it in
Nicaragua or anywhere else that in
America that it was hard to give one
word to it a mistake a tragic error I
came to see it as criminal in many ways
in the sense that it broke laws of our
own country our Constitution and
Internet
in law in many ways but even people who
did not and I base that on documents in
the exam my experiences in Vietnam and
that wasn't a judgment that was shared
by everybody who opposed that war but it
was enough to see that it was war that
must end and it did end because of our
founders of our Constitution their
wisdom in providing ways for the
Congress to leash in to rein in an
executive out of control was one of the
major reasons for separating from
England and all to get out from the
tyranny of autocratic executive control
and the provision for Congress to cut
off the money enabled Congress to end
that war and public demand by cutting
off the funding for the bomb that is the
way I think the arms race can be ended I
think it's really the only way it can be
ended Congress must take that
responsibility for suspending money as
the house did last before Iceland in a
strong majority vote cut off the funding
for the testing of nuclear weapons so
long as the Soviets were not testing no
Soviet testing no US testing that was
say strong majority vote and now with a
Democratic Senate I think that there's a
real prospect that the Congress as a
whole will do that if they do they'll be
doing something that has really one
precedent that was the way the Vietnam
War was ended that's a precedent of
power and of success we'll take our
first telephone call from Milwaukee
Wisconsin go ahead please good evening
mr. Ellsberg how you doing oh you wish
and I look good wasn't sent into these
in a survivor of the USS Liberty attack
that was back in 1967 I'm sure you
remember it well pardon me you are a
survivor yes I am sorry the crew of the
Liberty feels it was a deliberate attack
and we've been trying for the last 20
years to to come out with this and have
a government come forward and
you know their full story I'm sure you
could shed some light on this to feel
that the government will ever come out
with the true story to satisfy us and
would you with your knowledge of the
government at that time be willing to
help us with our plight I certainly
would have i have studied that not in
detail and i didn't know if it
officially the details at the time what
i've studied is i'm sure you're aware is
that there is very strong evidence the
circumstances of the attack the
prolongation of it the targeting
suggests very strongly that it was a
deliberate Israeli attack probably
intended to keep the u.s. from knowing
the Israeli counter-attack plans at that
point the fact that they plan to launch
an offensive at that moment and they
deliberately chose to hit an allies ship
in the fear that the president if he
knew that if he had that intelligence
indication might act on it the to
restrain them by the way to bring that
up to date that's a very obviously there
is strong the strong basis for our close
relationship with Israel and at the same
time there couldn't be a more
spectacular demonstration if you like
that our ally any allies interests may
at a given moment sharply diverge from
those of the US by the fact that our
ally Israel could could actually
deliberately and without admitting it
covertly attack an American ship and
caused casualties as the strongest
illustration of that obviously we're
seeing that in the current situation and
I think that you're the example that you
bring up is one the American people
should reflect on to impart understand
how it came to be that having chosen an
ally the Israelis in this case to be our
agents in dealing with Iran we put
ourselves in a position where we were
subject to some manipulation and to
actions that were not really in our
interest c-span will be carrying this
Friday at 6:00 p.m. a call in program
with David Horowitz and Peter Collier
former
editors of ramparts magazine the topic
will be perspectives on the Vietnam War
their article in commentary magazine
another low dishonest decade on the left
they will be taking a view somewhat
contrary to that expressed by our guest
tonight in it we hope you will be here
for that program we'll take another call
now this one from Burbank California go
ahead please good copy unit can you hear
me
good evening we hear you loud and clear
okay yeah mister ellsberg i sir
i just like to say God bless you for
helping get us out of Vietnam I mean Lou
because I was going to be next and you
know I would you know and I I supported
the Contras to I thought well you know
not because I like them not because of
the corporate country involved but you
know and I thought by doing that that
maybe our government might have learned
the right lesson but it doesn't seem
like that's what's happened I don't care
if you're Democrat Republican in between
or you don't know what's going on if
you're going to support the Contras then
it takes the American people support and
I think that's something that our our
government officials have forgotten and
we're kind of lucky to have a Daniel
Ortega because if we do support the
Contras then all of a sudden our our
public officials are asked the question
what do we stand for and it's something
they want to you know something they
haven't addressed yet anyhow I thought I
got a cute little song it's only four
verses and it's for the members of
Congress and I know you'll love it I
know your mother put and it's not
something you have to respond to but I
think you are worthy of hearing it and
if you can bear with me it's just four
verses it goes like this Congress was
dead Loftus must not too long I voted
aid to the Contras I've got to be strong
against communism
I voted aid to the Contras now I will
win my next briolette Shan
I voted hade to the culture
as a to the region will trip everyone I
vote in aid to the Contras does that
doesn't occur agua when the United
States and the Soviet Union does that
look like a Chernobyl waiting to happen
and I'll hang up and I'll let you
respond and God bless you well thank you
you give me various things to respond to
there I must say I'm forced to reflect
on the fact that I was a contra in
Vietnam I worked I was an American
contrary in the sense in which President
Reagan proclaims himself a contra now
called a revolutionary against the
revolutionary national movement I was
trying to win that war for America and I
I and for the people of Vietnamese who
were on our side who could well have
been called Contras at that point a lot
of them were my friends I certainly can
have sympathy in that sense for the
people who are I think many of them very
sincerely the younger people in that
country who have joined the countries
just in the spirit in which people
worked on the American side in Vietnam
and yet sympathy and a kind of pity for
people who find themselves working
essentially for foreigners in a cause
which cannot and does not have the
support of most of their country people
men and women it's a hopeless cause
situation for them to be in and it's not
a situation for us to be and hiring
people to do that to fight against their
own countrymen I can also recognize I
think from what I've heard the Contra
leaders from the information we have and
I think what we're going to be getting
in terms of the leaders the Contra
leaders we backed in Vietnam
those Vietnamese too were drug runners
murderers terrorists not all of them as
I say some of them were close friends of
mine people that I respected and others
were people that the United States
should not have had as agents and should
not have called allies and that seems
very clearly to be true of a number of
the Contra leaders who we inherited from
the regime of Somoza so I was in Vietnam
because I thought that the presence of
Americans
would be good for that country for those
people there were a lot of bombers along
with me and napalm and troops who are
getting shot at and shooting and our
presence wasn't good for that country or
this country and I think that would be
true in Nicaragua Birmingham Alabama do
you have a question or a comment good
evening good evening mr. Ellsberg oh I
was at the Chicago nuclear freeze
convention last month and went to a
couple of your workshops and you are
absolutely wonderful I want you to know
that and the urgency being from Alabama
I want to ask you what is your opinion
of how we can best influence
conservative congressmen conservative
senators to vote for ending the arms
race our congressman here in Alabama our
Senate senators for the most part
they've always voted for the MS they've
always voted for Star Wars how can we
influence conservative southern
politicians to vote in the arms race
well the reason I've been talking about
Congress somewhat more than the
executive here tonight is because
Congress as shown in the Vietnam War in
other cases is more responsive to the
people they're closer to them they have
smaller constituencies they hear more
for their constituents then that single
or two elected men at the head of the
executive branch far more responsive and
in large part because they face
re-election every two years in the house
or six years otherwise there's an old
expression in Washington about Congress
if they don't see the light they may yet
feel the heat and you speak how you can
influence your conservative congressmen
or senators house and the answer
ultimately certainly should reason with
them and let them know what you feel and
what it takes to represent your
attitudes and those of your colleagues
and those who agree with you and you
should also let them know that they work
for you that they are your servants
that's the glory of this country that's
what we do fight for in our wars to
defend and it's worth fighting for our
Wars do not always serve that cause of
democracy very well but it's what the
people fighting the war the fighting
level believe themselves to be fighting
for and they're not wrong to think that
it's worth it
so you should let
know that they will be fired if they
don't carry out the will of their
constituents not just yours of course
but - you should work to make that a
majority help make it a majority opinion
and that can be done very specifically
you can let them know that what you want
of them as your representatives and
public servants is to use their
constitutional power in the Senate as
well as the house to do what the house
did last fall and that is to vote to
suspend all to cut off all testing for
nuclear weapons so long as the Soviets
do not test that could end testing
forever whatever President Reagan or his
successors feels about it that would be
the public will the great majority of
the American people do want that to
happen just as they want an overall
freeze and the administration has been
ignoring that as as they have been
ignoring a number of other things it's
time now for them to feel the heat from
Congress how does the nuclear freeze
movement go about lobbying Congress
aside from the demonstrations you staged
from time to time here in Washington the
freeze movement on the whole was well
they had very large demonstrations
letter-writing lobbying of the usual
sort which is which means having
informed representatives in Washington
going to the offices of the congressman
letting them know what bills we support
and helping them draft legislation in
some cases in a number of cases the
freeze brought encourage people to come
on their own to Washington for major
days of lobbying it's only quite late in
the game that the freeze movement which
wanted to distinguish itself from the
protest movements of the 60s to tell the
truth and therefore stood aloof from the
tactic of civil disobedience for example
only really quite recently did it come
to endorse actions of the kind that are
going to happen at Nevada State tomorrow
as a matter of fact tomorrow morning the
27th where Martin Sheen is probably
going to be arrested with Kris
Kristofferson protesting nuclear testing
on the anniversary of the first nuclear
test there that demonstration will
include acts
civil soliciting will be both
demonstrations I think there'll be a
presence here at the deal week on
February 5th we expect really quite a
major protest blockade as I say this is
not a freeze action this is an action
however which the freeze and sane have
endorsed there will be an action of rock
aid of that test site trying to delay
symbolically with our bodies the first
American nuclear test of 1987 because
that test according to the Soviets will
end their moratorium they will feel free
to bruise oome testing after 18 months
of no tests which means that that test
will restart a two-sided test case test
program in my opinion for the President
to start the Soviets testing again by
continuing our testing on February 5th
would be an act as unwise desperately
unwise as his first shipment of arms to
Iran we need to help him by resisting
that policy san diego california go
ahead please um mister ellsberg i think
if you as one of Democracies martyrs in
a sense and that i imagine that you must
have paid a pretty big price both
professionally legally personally
economically for what you did is that
one true to you have any regrets and it
sounds like from the integrity and mark
it down and three would there be any
advice that you'd have to potential
whistleblowers either in government and
corporate service today who may have to
make moral choices that really could
affect their professional or economic
future thank you well thank you for what
she said
actually I don't think of myself as a
martyr and it wouldn't be appropriate
for anyone to think of me that way the
the White House in those days had
intended that I be a martyr of some kind
but they failed they were the ones who
went to jail
on the whole President Nixon himself was
impeached in part because he he thought
about me he had me more on his mind and
was good for him but in fact they failed
to make me a martyr at all so my wife
was with me throughout that ordeal of
the trial and that is an ordeal and we
go to closer than ever and that's the
core of my life I have a new young son
and a lot of friends in I do have to say
that my friends are mostly new friends
because everyone I'd known had a
clearance really in the 15 years that I
worked for the executive branch I was
kind of leper after that trial being
with me at all I think I've learned
indirectly from some of them led them to
feel that it would jeopardize their
careers of course many disagreed with
what I'd done very intensely others who
didn't still felt that they couldn't
afford to associate with me so I lost
essentially all of my friends with a
very few exceptions obviously that was a
big price but there is life outside the
executive branch there are lot of
friends available who don't have
clearances and the new friends I've made
are very valuable to me for those of you
who may have forgotten how big the
Pentagon Papers case and Dad Daniel
Ellsberg's role in it was back in the
1970s I would refer to you to the book
by Woodward and Bernstein all the
president's men and let me read a line
from that book the disclosure that Hunt
and Liddy two of the convicted figures
in Watergate had supervised the burglary
of Daniel Ellsberg's psychiatrists
office had inextricably linked Watergate
in the Ellsberg trial in Los Angeles in
the post newsroom the two stories were
often referred to as Watergate East and
Watergate West is that the reference
wing back memories well I remember the
day when it it was revealed in the court
that that the White House plumbers Hunt
and Liddy who did correspond in function
and sort of role to Colonel North and
some of the other had burgled the
psychoanalyst office Watergate had been
big news on the East Coast for a while
and the reporters covering my trial
certainly felt that they were in a
backwater they said you know my god
Watergate meets the Pentagon Papers it
was exciting for them
but it was it was exciting for us and of
course it did lead to the end of the
trial New York City you are on c-span hi
yes I heard Mr Ellsberg in New York City
on WBAI radio and I found sounded very
interesting my question is sort of
related to that I there's a program they
have there called contra gate between
8:00 and 8:30 and I listened to it
pretty regularly when I wake up and I
hear all kinds of stories on this this
radio show about contra drug connections
a plot to kill ambassador Thames the
Ambassador to Costa Rica that the
Contras and the CIA were set up and a
host of other stories which are they
they make they make the Reagan
administration same seem like really
traitors and what what I don't
understand is why I don't hear this in
the mainstream press and I'm just
wondering if most of these stories are
fabrications by this radio station WBAI
or if this is really happening in the
press is not reporting it well I just
spent last evening talking to a very
fine American a very patriotic and
dedicated American named Daniel Sheehan
who is working for subsistence wages as
a lawyer in a public interest law firm
religious based public interest law firm
called Christic Institute and they have
taken on the defense of two Americans
named Tony Aragon and Martha honey and
named as defendants in this suit
twenty-nine officials on sorry a slight
slip but not entirely 29 individuals
many of them former officials or the
United States government that they
charge as having been conspirators in a
long criminal conspiracy violating laws
of this country which in part had the
effect of severely injuring Tony
Allergan when he was covering a press
conference of Eden Pastora
contra leader in Costa Rica and the
charge with a good deal of I was reading
now a lot of the evidence
have in the affidavit that supports that
suit is that these people some of whom
were then American officials at the time
we're involved in trying to kill Aiden
pester because he wouldn't cooperate
with the CIA the suit also involves
these same individuals in plotting to
kill with witnesses and participants
Lois Thames that you mentioned the
ambassador of Costa Rica who was by the
way a great contra supporter and for
that very reason was a candidate for
assassination by these Contras because
his assassination was to be blamed
according to the suit on which is a
sworn affidavit on the Sandinistas and
be used as a provocation or an excuse
for an American attack on Nicaragua
something like the Tonkin Gulf
provocations that were involved that led
to our attacks in North Vietnam I read a
good deal I say the evidence supporting
this some of this is about to come out
if these allegations are true and I I
can vouch that it's my judgment that
Danny Sheehan of the Christic Institute
defender deserves great support I'm very
impressed by them and if these
allegations are true and are proven in
court we will see that our government
has engaged and what can only be
described as a criminal conspiracy
whether or not it was authorized by the
President of the United States we don't
hire a president we don't elect a
president to break the laws of the
United States to murder or injure
American citizens and otherwise break
laws such as Neutrality Act or the
Boland Amendment forbidding money going
down to Nicaragua his oath that we
demand of him in the Constitution is to
take care that the laws are faithfully
executed so whether or not the president
was aware the allegations make a pattern
of what the suit calls racketeering and
that's not the business our government
should be in I want to inject at this
time into this discussion an article
that I know you disagree with the
article we referred to earlier that will
be the subject of a c-span callin
program on Friday at 6 o'clock it is
called another low dishonest decade on
the
left the authors are Peter Collier and
David Horowitz David Horowitz being I
believe a former close friend of yours
is that true and they are quite critical
of the new left and one of their
criticisms is the post-vietnam left is
always ready to believe the official
soviet lie give the Soviets the benefit
of the doubt or where the abuses are too
great at least to understand in quotes
horrific Soviet acts as a legitimate
reflexive fear of American power your
response well I think that's
slanderously wrong I'm very dismayed to
hear my former friend was a brilliant
analyst of the Cold War and a strong
leader in the fight against Vietnam say
such a thing he has certain elements of
the Left known personally to him very
intimately of whom that could probably
be said to be true a very tiny minority
of the American public and of the
anti-war movement but as a description
of the majority moving specifically of
the movement and nuclear arms race that
couldn't be less true the freeze
movement of which I'm part was an
original sponsor put great emphasis on
stopping Soviet testing deployment
production of weapons because we regard
the Soviet weapons it's enormous we
threatening to the world security having
the capability obviously like ours of
ending life on earth and it seems to us
extremely important that there should be
no new Soviet weapons no more Soviet
weapons indeed that there should be
enormous ly less we don't know any way
of achieving that that lead let's the
United States continue to proliferate
weapons not that we would like that to
happen anyway it's obvious that that can
only be done by a mutual freeze but the
people who most claim that the
anti-nuclear movement is pro-soviet
slanderously and i i must very sorrowful
ii include the president in that his
statements to that effect have to be
described in my opinion as slanderous
whether he knows better I don't know I
stated Horowitz certainly does know
better but those people led
by the president seemed to have no
concern at all how many weapons new
weapons the Soviets have the Soviets
have in effect passed the switch to
their own testing to President Reagan
they've said if you don't test in 1987
there will be no Soviet tests just as
there were none in 1986 as I said before
for him to press that button by testing
an American weapon is deeply foolish to
do it in the name of anti-communism is
bizarre it what it means is that the
president thinks it doesn't matter how
many tests the Soviets make how many new
weapons they make as long as we test
more as we have as long as we have more
weapons I think that's deeply foolish
and that as foolish as some of the other
policies were running about now and it's
up to us as American citizens to change
those policies how about the Reagan
administration argument that we have to
resume testing because we have fallen
behind the Soviets in the development of
a new generation of nuclear weapons
well it's false we've conducted some 24
tests while they haven't tested any in
the last 18 months and even so as DoD
Department of Defense and Department of
Energy spokesmen have made clear people
at Livermore Laboratory for example of
major we're ahead in virtually every
qualitative aspect of the arms race
certainly in such things as the x-ray
laser of the I will say the Reagan
administration did make the claim that
the Soviets could have an x-ray laser a
bomb pumped x-ray laser a major part of
the president's Star Wars program
without further testing that was so
false that Livermore Laboratory not a
very not what David Horowitz would
include in the the left-wing
particularly Livermore Laboratory made
statements saying no no that was not
true video II they certainly could not
have such a weapon without more testing
I'll say by the way I don't want the
Soviets to have an x-ray laser the only
way to stop them is for us to forego our
having such a weapon and that's a very
good bargain for us Eugene Oregon sorry
to keep you waiting go ahead please okay
hi
yeah I'd like to thank mister ellsberg
for having the courage to turn over the
Pentagon Papers to the American people
I'm a Vietnam veteran and I currently
own a small business up here in the
northwest I'd like to comment on the
conscious situation that is developing
now I have to take exception when when
c-span mentions that he referred to the
people being liberals that are against
against the conscience but the latest
poll that that I heard said that 68% of
the American people don't agree with
President Reagan's policy in Central
America and certainly all of them can't
can't be liberal now it seems to me that
if the Reagan administration wanted to
wants to modify the sandanista regime to
for a long line their way of thinking
they could have accomplished this and
them to a much greater extent through
economic help instead of spending a
billion dollars on the Contras and
trying to starve the Nicaraguan economy
if the Reagan administration had
economically tried to help the
Nicaraguan government that they could
have gotten a lot more for their dollar
and I was wondering well mister ellsberg
how he what he feels about the
administration's chances of getting
another hundred million dollars for the
Contras I mean seems like we're getting
close to having spent about a half a
billion dollars or so on that group of
people and I believe that there would be
a lot fewer Contras joining up if we
weren't putting the economic squeeze on
that small Central American country and
I also think that the Contra leaders and
lieutenants and officers are a bunch of
thugs and I like your your comments Lee
well I obviously agree with virtually
everything you've said very specifically
on the first point you raised about the
who it is in the American public who
opposes this the poll I saw last week I
believe it was a Gallup poll but widely
reported showed a majority of
Republicans opposing aid to the Contras
just as by the way a majority of public
Republicans would like to see the
president
negotiate a bilateral nuclear freeze in
both cases the president is ignoring the
desire of a majority of his own
constituency you may or may not have
noticed that it came out during the
Republican convention nominating Reagan
last in the last election they did a
poll of the convention delegates there
and a majority of them were for the
freeze so to characterize these
attitudes as the attitudes of a smaller
second segment of the United States
Society is is quite foolish as you say
and of course I agree very much on the
other lines that you said you do not
make a society more liberal by
terrorizing its countryside which is
essentially what the Contras are doing
but I I think I should add one thing to
what you said I think it's misleading
for us to look at the policy of the
United States which is very clearly I
was talking about presidents Reagan's
policy I made a slip there myself policy
of our executive branch under President
Reagan is very clearly to overthrow the
government of Nicaragua the Sandinistas
I don't believe that they think really
in the Pentagon my former colleagues
there and people who are in Vietnam that
they will do that by the Contras alone
I'm sure the president is being told
that the only way to do that would be by
us American armed attack or invasion
I don't believe by the way the Joint
Chiefs are recommending that or ever
have if anything I think they've been a
moderating we
rural influence if you like on that
point but they will follow the orders
undoubtedly if the president should send
them an e if Congress doesn't succeed in
in pre-empting it and stopping it
cutting off funds and getting that stop
I think we prior to conjugate which is
probably weakened the president's
ability to do this politically I think
we had a very significant risk of having
pictures like that come back from
Nicaragua possibly as early as this
spring and we may not be have entirely
eliminated that risk because I think the
president's incentive to distract us
with a little war will grow very great
as he faces talk and I'm not being
rhetorical here now as he faces serious
talk of impeachment and the destruction
of his administration so I think we have
to be as Thomas Jefferson said vigilant
about our leadership in the months ahead
if we're to avoid the body bags and
having the cover of Time and Newsweek
look like that every week a picture like
that that you referred there was not on
camera at the moment I am showing it now
it is the cover of this week's Time
magazine and cover story about the the
movie platoon which some think is one of
the movies that is changing the
perception of the Vietnam War
I'd like to ask you if you think movies
of this sort which time calls the best
movie made about the Vietnam War in the
sense of being more realistic whether
they have the power to change the
American perception about that war and
what degree that change in perception
might be affecting the American attitude
toward getting involved in Nicaragua
well there aren't any movies of that
sort unfortunately that's unique in my
experience that's not just the best
movie made about Vietnam the Vietnam War
it's the only movie about the Vietnam
War and so far I hope there will be
others that strive for that standard
it's an astounding movie I would say
it's the only realistic movie about war
as I saw it in
that's ever been made and I'm extremely
happy to see the lines when I saw it the
other night I saw the longest lines in
my hometown that I'd ever seen for movie
and I was very encouraged to see that I
would like every voting American and
every American who isn't yet voting it
is coming to be of draft age young male
to see that movie shortly I would like I
would love Congress to have to see that
movie as a whole I think that would end
the Contra aid that the previous
listener asked about I can't believe
that they would vote money to send
American boys to kill and die in such
similar conditions in Nicaragua if
they'd seen the realism of that movie
Springfield Virginia and the snowbound
Washington suburbs do you have a
question or a comment for Daniel
Ellsberg yes
Ellsberg well I would probably fall
within the 80% of people at um they
would like to see the nuclear arms race
stopped I think there would be a
significant number of less people as a
percentage that support the way groups
such as yours would want to go about it
you happen to mention you know mutant
the Soviets hadn't tested and but there
was a significant number of people you
you you may be personally concerned
about not being so naive as to trust the
Soviets completely but there are a
significant number of individuals that
support you who call for unilateral
disarmament who believe that if we don't
attack Moscow that they'll leave us
alone and that basically support an
isolationist the sentiment in this
country that prevailed prior to world
war two that barring an attack on
Washington that there's nowhere in the
world that the America should ever have
to use military force and I think that
that sentiment is one of the reasons
you'll have a difficult time selling the
many people may agree with the positions
that you take the message that you would
go about it they won't agree with and I
don't think as a world power we're if
would you support personally that if we
gave no money to the Contras at all
and the Sandinistas invaded Honduras or
anywhere else down there that we then to
attack them or would you say well when
that's no threat either is there any
place in the world other than attack on
Washington DC that you feel would be
justified using American force when I
enlisted in the Marine Corps
in 1954 it was with the example of the
North Korean attack across the border
into South Korea I went in during the
Korean emergency although actually the
fighting had essentially ended by the
time I got in and I went in feeling that
I was proud of my country that it
accepted a role as part of a UN leading
a UN police force there against the
principle of aggression I thought it
wasn't presented as a unilateral action
I wasn't I wasn't didn't face that
particular issue of should we take on
the role of the world's policeman alone
it was certainly put to us that the UN
we did have the full support of the UN
in opposing that aggression you've
described a situation of hypothetical
aggression by the NIP Nicaraguans into
Honduras and if the OAS called for
denounced as aggression and called for
combined action against that I would
think that that would could very well be
appropriate and with a within American
values in other words I'm as opposed to
aggression now as I was when I was in
the Marines in the 50s obviously that's
not what we're seeing down there we're
seeing a force that is hired managed
controlled equipped against the law of
our country against the wishes of
Congress during 52 from 54 to 56 hired
by Americans run by Americans going
across the border to do largely murder
against a civilian population some
attacks on military forces of that
country in that country that is
aggression I don't want my country ever
to be the aggressor it is right now and
it has been on other occasions that's
the policy I and I'll bet you and a lot
of Americans want to see changed
Martinez California if I'm pronouncing
that correctly
correct me if I'm not go ahead please
yes mister ellsberg I'd like to ask you
a question I would I don't consider
Russell banks exactly a conservative yet
this gentleman is going around the
United States of America unfortunately
he hasn't been on c-span raising money
for the Mosquito Indians who today and
everyday are being more murdered
tortured and killed by the Sandinistas
government that the catholic church in
nicaragua nicaragua has their their
radio station their television station
they're a way to communicate with the
people been shut down by the communist
butchers in that country that the
constitution which was an excellent
constitution that they they just passed
was suspended three days after they
passed it that there's no civil rights
in that country at all there's no free
press in that country at all and there's
about four hundred thousand people who
have decided with their legs to show you
what they think of the great sandanista
government and their residing now in
refugee camps in Costa Rica and Honduras
and I suggest to you that the instead of
calling it
Nicaragua gate or whatever you want to
call it why don't you call it Afghani
Gate because some of this money went to
the Afghan freedom fighters who are
fighting the Russian tanks with their
Molotov cocktails I haven't seen you do
one thing not one thing to condemn the
Russians about Afghanistan where they
make hang grenades like boys so guilty
the kids can play with them and blow
themselves up you know I haven't heard
you say D are you asking about your
people are you asking me my dearest Anna
Stan I'm glad to give it to you man of
their own people been murdered by the
communists they're the refugees from
Vietnam that you led down the primrose
path the communism where people jump on
both with the with their life in danger
and leaving that country in droves we're
running a little short of time let's
give mr. Ellsberg a chance to respond
I don't want Nicaragua to be our
Afghanistan as Vietnam was as the
Soviets or aggressors in Afghanistan
they're terrorists in Afghanistan how do
I know because I see them doing the same
operations with 50 caliber machine gun
I read about it I read the effects I see
pictures of it that we did in Vietnam
and that was aggression that was
invasion that was terrorism
I don't want our country to imitate the
Soviet brutality and that as they're
imitating ours now in short I don't want
us to have as I say another Afghanistan
or Vietnam in Nicaragua the various in
justices brutalities that you speak of
in Nicaragua the other limitations of
that government which characterize a
country at war and don't in many cases
compared unfavorably with our own
performance at war and extraordinarily
better than the performance of our
allies like El Salvador Guatemala which
I haven't heard you mention the fact is
put them at their worst put them at you
describe them somewhat exaggerated but
they're real you are talking about real
false real brutalities of that regime
down there put them at their worst do
they justify American invasion of that
country do they justify your sons and
brothers and others and you're voting
taxes to send down an invasion of that
country in my opinion no you have a
right to vote your taxes that way but
you're in a minority of Americans and I
thank God for that where you have a
switchboard lit up and only about nine
minutes to go if you'll keep your
question short we'll see how many more
we can get in Little Rock Arkansas go
ahead please good evening miss Ellsberg
have you later
against all odds that came out of Cuba
with an arrow for 25 years I know is
that a valid Auris the president I would
yeah I've heard that's very good look
have you read the book no I've heard of
it I read with you I would be very close
with you if you read the book and then
maybe you understand why it is so
important that Nicaragua does not remain
communist I like to remind you of course
that Vietnam today is a hell on earth as
if Cambodia is only because the United
States was unable to finish its job in
Vietnam
it's a fact today that the Vietnamese
people on both sides are worse of way
worse often the where would have been if
America had won at war let's Lecter
can we let mr. Ellsberg respond yes one
small point I think that's worth making
you know understanding the situation the
administration routinely describes
Nicaragua as if it were as unfree a
country as Cuba in either its various
aspects that's grotesquely untrue there
are many parties in allowed in Nicaragua
which in fact I have witnessed are free
to criticize and do criticize take part
in the assembly in a way that is not
true in Cuba is not true in the eastern
bloc there are that difference but I
don't want to press that point it
doesn't bear too much on what we're
talking about today the question is will
the liberties of the Nicaraguans and the
welfare of Nicaraguans be improved if
the United States reproduces in
Nicaragua what we did in Vietnam and
what the Soviets are now doing in
Afghanistan in my opinion very
tragically not if you were a Cuban it
would seem to me understandable that you
would individually you would have every
right and seemed to be very
understandable to feel that there were
things happening in your country that
offended you terribly that needed to be
changed that deserved even revolutionary
efforts on your part if you called in as
I'm not saying that you're Cuban
hypothetically here if you were to call
in misguidedly as some Cubans have done
hoping that Americans for combat help
hoping that American bombers would help
free your country you would be making
the same tragic mistake that the people
I worked with in Vietnam made something
would happen to that country of Nick of
Cuba and Nicaragua and if you think that
hell on earth is where the Vietnamese
are now and imagine they would be better
off if we were still bombing them you
were terribly misguided Santa Barbara
California you are next go ahead please
yes another question for Daniel Ellsberg
Lebanon do you think US troops with the
appropriate use of military force that
we go in and clean up all the terror uh
I hope that's a kind of rhetorical
question because I think the American
people getting a good look at Lebanon
correctly saw that the President had
made an almost incomprehensible error in
committing American marines in small
numbers or large had he done so to
Lebanon and it was democratic pressure I
think that caused them to reverse his
policy and pull those Marines out after
they had suffered serious terrorist
casualties in there again a situation
where there are terrible rights and
wrongs on not just both sides one has to
speak of dozens of sides in that country
and it's a kind of morass in which for
the United States to think that we could
go in there and police and bring order
to that situation would be the kind of
arrogance of old men in power that would
lead again to the deaths of innumerable
young Americans lied in their by their
leaders and innumerable Lebanese for
many Lebanese right now Lebanon is a
place of hell if American bombers were
added to the individual terrorist
bombers that are terrorizing that place
you would not see order you would see a
new order of hell that the Lebanese are
not yet conceived of Freeport Illinois
we have time for your call if you'll
keep your question short go ahead please
I'd like to call your attention to an
article in The Wall Street Journal notes
Thursday January the 15th that sighted
137 cases from 1798 to 1970 where
executive actions was committed without
approvals Congress you keep throwing
around the Constitution in the
violations of statutes of statutes are
different in Congress could
constitutional law and the War Powers
Act Boland amendment things like this
have never been checked to their
constitutionality
would you have any comment yes indeed
the the War Powers Act is an attempt by
Congress to regain some of the powers
that were clearly specifically laid out
for Congress exclusively the power to
declare war the power to raise armies
and to make war essentially given
exclusively to not the direction of the
war to Congress and which powers which
had been terribly eroded not by law not
by court decisions but by the practice
of president after President as you
described some of those early ones were
small naval raids rather small
demonstrations some were not so small
President Wilson for example great
Democratic liberal occupied Nicaragua
for many years as he occupied Haiti and
Dominican Republic with American marines
not the Marines finest hour in actual
fact and not Wilson's finest hour but
that sort of thing on a much greater
scale in the cold warrior after second
law did indeed erode Congress's role to
a point where people were almost willing
to say well they're not really in it
anymore that's outmoded Vietnam revealed
to us that that constitutional power
needed to be revived the reason the
president seems to have broken laws in
giving aid to Nicaragua right now to the
Contras is that there was a law to break
Congress had made a law which had no
precedent before Vietnam Vietnam had
taught Congress its responsibilities in
its power to act constitutionally to
rein in the President and that's why
when he ignored them he was not just
doing something unpolitical he was
acting illegally our guest has been
Daniel Ellsberg an activist in the
nuclear freeze movement and author of
one of the Pentagon Papers during the
Vietnam War thank you very much for
being with us thank you thanks to our
c-span viewers for your calls and
comments have a pleasant evening